For this quiz I want you
to fix this website.
You'll be trying out
Calc with these images.
But this time,
I want you to fit these three images
all the way across the screen.
Each of the three images will need to
be a third of the available width, and
there should be a ten
pixel margin between them.
Pop open dev tools and inside
the head you'll find this style tag.
Inside the style tag,
you'll see some comments.
These are the places where I
want you to make some changes.
You can find a link to the website
in the instructor notes.
When all three images
are aligned correctly,
with ten pixels between these images,
a code will appear on the website.
Type that code into
this box to continue.